throughout the film one of the
storylines the audience follows is Jacob
toretto's quest to get Little Brian to
safety the parameters of the mission are
vague even by fast and furious standards
though things got even more confusing
when a character reveals that Brian
O'Connor the former franchise co-lead
played by the late Paul Walker is
somehow entirely safe from harm with his
own family what makes a story Choice
frustrating is that it's such an
unimaginative solution to an obvious
problem that creates more questions than
it answers while it's understandable why
FastTech would want to address his
character in some way simply not
mentioning him at all would arguably be
preferable to this if it was a matter of
involving their late co-star in the
story somehow they were surely more
meaningful ways to do so that leaves a
series in an awkward place as darm and
the rest of the family need to
acknowledge that the brine character
still exists without actually bringing
him back into the story maybe it would
have been better for that acknowledgment
to have never come up especially since
Dante doesn't seem to have any trouble
finding any of the other characters that
he's seeking revenge against